يبدو انا معجزه جديده يعني تحدث للتو الان
وصلوا الى شخص على قيد الحياه وهم في حاله
من الصدمه لانهم لم يتوقعوا ذلك طلبوا
يعني معدات طبيه طلبوا اطباء وطلبوا اشخاص
يقوموا بازاله الحطام حتى يتسنى لهم
اخراجه طبعا كانوا طلبوا منا الصمت قبل
قليل ونحن معك على الهواء صحيح وبين فعلا
انه على قيد الحياه في هذه النقطه التي
يعملون فيها
هنالك يعني صراخ كثير وارباك لانهم لم
يكنوا يعني لم يكونوا يتوقعوا فعلا ان
يخرج شخص
مع تقريبا نهايه اليوم السابع فيه وخصوصا
ان ساعات المساء طاهر بارده جدا وهو اكبر
تحدي قد يواجه الشخص الذي يتواجد تحت
الانقاض نحن سنبقي عينا على هذه الصوره
معك طاهر لحين اخراجه
عامل الانقاذ الذي توصل اليه كان يعني في
حاله صدمه يطلب يعني يصرخ ويطلب من مساعده
في ان ياتي عمال الانقاذ الى جانبه لازاله
الركام الذي يحيط بالجثه بالشخص عفوا الذي
لا يزال على قيد الحياه ويطلب مساعده طلب
من احد الاطباء ان يقترب ومعه سماعه
واقترب فعلا وذهب الى تلك النقطه لا يسمح
انت كما تشاهد الشرطه اغلقت المكان يعني
لا يسمح لاحد ان يقترب الان ربما
لا خلي الاضاءه خلي الاضاءه خلي الاضاءه
خلي الاضاءه خلي الاضاءه خليه الاضاءه
خلي الاضاءه اتركها نحن
طاهر معك سنبقى عينا على هذه الصوره ما
حدث بانهم عثروا على شخص لا يزال على قيد
الحياه وطلبوا بحاله يعني حاله من الارباك
والصدمه المساعده لاخراجه
هم الان على ما يبدو اني انا رايت طبيبه
دخلت
وعلى ما يبدو انها امراه
الحيه التي تتواجد تحت انقاض هذا المبنى
الامر يعني لم يكن متوقعا بالنسبه لهم
لانه عمليات البحث عن ناجين طوال هذا
اليوم كانت مستمره
وكانوا فحصوا اكثر من نقطه واكدوا انه لا
وجود للحياه باي شخص ولكن للتو معجزه
جديده فعلا ان خرجت هذه السيده حيه ستكون
معجزه جديده وبالتالي ربما تعيد حساباتهم
فيما يتعلق بهذا المبنى وهذا هذه المنطقه
السكنيه باكملها والبحث من جديد عن اشخاص
ناجين